I got a DM the other day about somebody
who's like it's easy for you to build
this brand because you know you already
have this big audience he was
discouraged by the fact that he had no
following he had no audience Etc
everyone who sees the overnight success
right everyone's like oh man the mosey
style content's all over the place go to
my podcast and look at the time stamp of
my first episode it's 2017. six years
ago it just now hit the top ten six
years later so people are making
podcasts and thinking in 90 days they're
somehow going to blow up when the
reality is that you're finding your
voice for the first year and you're also
learning about the stuff that you're
learning meantime right like in that
period of time I might not have had as
much stuff that was as cool that applied
to as many people because the first 150
episodes is just me talking about how to
run a gym better